[Music]
three
two one action welcome back to off the
record where we talk about whatever we
want how do you
how do you intro it because i just copy
you
you lay the foundation i'm just like
carbon copy it carbon copy it oh
no i don't know because um i guess we
always we always get it wrong too
no it's not getting it wrong it's just
like i had never sat here
when you guys are doing it and so for me
it was like oh this is different
why do you guys switch this time because
he's hosting today i know why we like to
switch it up
that's when we scheduled it oh yeah this
is the first time this is the first time
you're
here with me hosting though and i'm
actually like next to you i'm actually
kind of nervous
when's the last time you got hot seated
hot seated
uh it feels like it's been years no when
steve when steve uh
he hosted a few times and i would sit
here but almost never like almost
never am i sitting in the seat does it
make the whole room look different it
does
it really is like a different position
over it's way different
so different the vibes feel different
yeah that's true i was just telling geo
like this morning and we're like i was
like the worst seats in this room is
nadeem seed right now and gio yeah we
don't see each other i see
his left eye i just don't like sitting
in that seat because then like
it that chair leans back and then
because i'm kind of fat
so it makes me look better right because
every time i sit there people like
did he gain weight and then when i sit
there people like damn they even lost
weight
really a week in between the videos so
it's like funny
it's you typing it you look good so it's
fine
i think this is the the hardest seat in
the house because no one looks at you or
acknowledges you
and everyone's looking this way oh yeah
yeah yeah that was my seat for many
many years and it's hard because you got
to be extra like attention grabbing
true i always look at joe through the
tripods
and i don't know if like on on cam so i
look at joe with my best angle
but i don't know if on camera looks like
outside
me and joe are always having heart to
hearts all the time oh okay
so you guys can see each other yeah yeah
we don't the best view
is probably like this angle for me
and people go joe never looks at i'm
like well because when someone's telling
me the information i'm not gonna be like
tell me the news tell me the details
please you viewers they don't realize
that we're in the same room
because every angle looks completely
different so a lot of people are always
like i don't know you guys were in the
same room
we should do one where it's uh one of
those 360 cameras they can turn the
camera themselves
for years that'd be pretty tight just
like one episode and they can control
the camera
yeah we have better internet now so i
think we can do it
true well it's not a live stream so i
guess we could do it now
yeah that's what's been holding us back
i know right
we finally got better internet now
that's true
yeah you get you telling me that there
was internet here i was like mind blown
yeah i'm sorry i'm so excited because
for the longest time we had to get
it was either 56k or it's even slower
than that i felt like [ __ ] yeah dude
it's dial up yeah it was two megabytes
per second or something and then we had
some
[ __ ] t1 because team one's supposed
to be like lightning fast but it's not
it was like what like one megabyte up
one megabyte
it was bad i did a speed test on it it
wasn't you just being cheap right
it was it wasn't dude it was it was 300
but i'm saying it wasn't like you like
if someone wants a choice
there was no choice like that oh it was
just satellite they didn't run a cable
in yeah and then two years ago i guess
they ran a cable in without telling us
because they only had dsl
and then we're like [ __ ] [ __ ]
man welcome to the 21st century did you
ever work the gym
when the gym was here yes that's where
he started off okay oh no i didn't i
didn't work
but i was there you were i was there
yeah man like with that stupid what the
[ __ ] [ __ ]
oh yeah you just hired yourself pretty
much yeah he was he would drive from the
bay
and then he was like working the desk
and we're like what the [ __ ] oh really
that's what he did yeah
because then they would like make me
work and then they'll go get food and
then they would like walk into like what
the [ __ ]
just some random kids working now some
random kid kid named chris is working
some random kid that looks 35. i didn't
start chris until the the new one oh
is it okay yeah we would have like so we
would have like this stupid 56k
connection and uh the whole like
uh pos system runs off that thing and
then so
[ __ ] piece of [ __ ] yeah so you're
working off it and then it would just
like
the member like try to scan and it
doesn't work
and then we're like you're like [ __ ]
we have to manually write all these
numbers
but then you know how like all of our
staff they're like goofballs
so people probably write like three of
the numbers and then they're like hey so
what you've been up to
and then we come back we're like okay
who do we check in today and it's all
[ __ ] up records we're like oh
[ __ ] so it was hard it was hard running
out of here
do you guys still use that system yeah
right like well we got normal internet
now that's good
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah we got normal
internet out which is awesome we just
know people's names too
you just check them in whenever they
walk in isn't it crazy that we ran
an internet company with no internet the
most ironic thing i know
it was so hard to do this because like
sometimes like in the middle of the day
like we get breaking news or whatever we
could even like
switch over and be like let's cover that
today because we'd have to download
everything the videos and we just
didn't have the internet to do that or
even like while we're filming it's like
oh tip google this thing really quick
and i'm like
why even i know right it's gonna take us
like 30 minutes to actually load a
picture it's like
trying to watch porn in junior high
oh the struggles oh no the dark the dark
shadows are returning to joe
those were the oh man those were so
difficult don't go back there in your
head man don't go back there
stay with us well the floppy disks i
don't know why it wasn't even watching
it's not even the [ __ ] theme do you
know what a floppy disk
would load up so slow and maybe the
computer couldn't
handle the [ __ ] high quality image it
was born on floppiness
that's how you sent gave it to each
other what's the worst porn you ever
jacked off to not the worst
not the worst that's like the most you
want to ask joe no not gonna lose
not the most sinful like not the most
regret quality
so i'll go first okay thank you whatever
example so when i first started getting
horny and i realized that i needed to
jack off
which is probably i don't know like
fifth grade where i was like climbing
those
lamp poles and stuff and that's great
okay
i was climbing lap holes way earlier but
um
uh but i needed more visual stimulus uh
stimulation yeah that works
stimuli i need more stimuli and uh
it was hard we didn't really have
internet back then too and then so
we what i found was um my mom had a
computer engineer friend that gave me
this
um flappy disc full of clip art
like trees and [ __ ] penguins oh i
thought going to say like of like chase
yeah i was like houses like straight up
like drawn images
okay it's still kind of weird and then i
remember one time just kind of scrolling
through like oh cool so like this will
make my
my book reports way better because i'll
be able to put a palm tree on the cover
page you know and then like no one else
had access
to the images and the one time i did see
uh a chick that was supposed to be a
pin-up doll and i'm like oh i'm gonna
save this one
there's another one where it was just
like uh almost like a cartoon like betty
boop version
of just like titties oh yeah yeah yeah
just titties
of just well that's what you said so it
was
that and i had to save those two
for whenever my mom was cooking in the
kitchen the minute i hear the range go
on i'm like time to climb somewhere
i go to my computer put that in wait
would you bring a lamp to the computer
it's already that's sort of really close
by oh i see i said climb some lamps what
does that mean oh cause you're not here
from that story no or you weren't here
faster either
long story i've been with you for 12
years i know you're not the [ __ ]
lance
he's a lap [ __ ] so you know so you
know i've been coming since i was like
maybe in kindergarten right
you could come in kindergarten it feels
good
dude that's talent so i've been climbing
these trees and i found out when i
climbed these trees or these poles and i
get to the top of my bust and nuts but i
didn't know
i'm just like oh it feels good when you
climb to the oh was it those rough trees
though or the smooth ones
it doesn't matter it's just the way i
moved my legs and i would always invite
all my friends we gotta climb poles you
guys don't understand
like we want to go on the swings man and
i'll get to the top and i'm still trying
to climb it because
because i'm about to come or whatever
and then like all my friends like you at
the top
and i'm like i know just wait feels good
no way he said just wait yeah i'm like
just wait i'll come back down
you're just up there [ __ ] it i'll be
more relaxed if i came back down
and people judge me for [ __ ] the
couch come on
that's weird though is it weird
climbing it's weird but pretty much
everyone's done it
yeah i look like climbing though because
in my pocket who [ __ ] a tree that's
like are you climbing it
but then you're like you're like humpty
dude that was me on the pole like
in because i remember i talked about
this like i think it was kindergarten no
it was in kindergarten it was like
second grade and i would be
climbing up like the monkey pole the
monkey bar yeah
and then yeah like i realized like now
that i'm an adult
i'm like holy [ __ ] i was humping that
pole because it felt good and i didn't
know why it felt good
there's a lot of kids humping poles a
lot of kids help everything
if i have a kid and then i see them like
just like staying extra long on like
those
i better leave them alone no i'm gonna
run up and grab
why i'll show them the proper way i'll
be like yo watch this and just
no letter that's worse disgusting let
him explore
like look on a [ __ ] tree when tycho
is climbing right now
i go oh [ __ ] is he about to do it oh my
knives doesn't matter
my
i don't know if i would see that i'm
like i'm not i don't see anything i'm
gonna go inside and i don't know you
figure it out
it's funny though mom
[Laughter]
it's so funny though watching it's like
watching dogs hump each other it's just
or
[ __ ] a basketball it's the funniest
thing it's very innocent yeah i don't
know
um you know what's crazy though is like
pretty much i'm pretty much clear with
my debt right so i did it all online
because this video is awesome so this
video is brought to you by
pop star baby
and i wish i knew about this way sooner
even though we're talking about climbing
poles i think
what's even more of a relief is to being
debt-free
hell yeah that's a huge relief huge
yeah yeah a lot of stress a lot of
anxiety yeah you're not gonna be able to
climb anything
you can and what they don't tell you
during the cl climbing days of school
is that they don't tell you how
important it is to have good credit
because then later when you buy a car or
you buy a house yeah
like i don't know a cell phone it's if
you have bad credit it could ruin
your life and ruin the choices that you
make so if your credit
is in your debts all mixed it's already
messed up right now it's really
important to try to consolidate
everything which is why upstart is
awesome because you can take all of it
wrap it into one easy fixed rate payment
because a lot of these credit cards also
if you make one late payment it already
gains you [ __ ] hard yeah you know
what's crazy they all have different
aprs too so when you consolidate then
you just have to worry about just one
entrance
yeah and when you always request or like
inquire for a loan they pull your credit
which hurts your credit score
but upstart they don't pull your credit
like that
they go based off of like your education
history your job
and all these other things and then they
kind of use this
different way of factoring in how much
you qualify for the loan
and it goes up to like 50 grand whoa i
know which is super awesome so see why
upstart has a 4.9 out of 5 rating on
trustpilot
and hurry to upstart.com record to find
out how low your upstart rate can be
checking your rate only takes a few
minutes and i highly recommend this
especially if you're being proactive and
trying to make your credit
better and you don't want to have like
10 payments you have to worry about
that's upstart.com
record r-e-c-o-r-d and your loan amount
will be
determined based on your credit income
and other information provided in your
loan application
go get it and clear that debt yep and
get that relief
get that relief that financial relief
dude i mean right now i'm trying to go
back into debt though
why because there's credit so you can
use the upstart
i might be because if if if they do
personal loans
because right now interest rates
are so dang low global i wasn't gonna
buy a house till next year
but i'm i'm gonna try to get a loan for
a home yeah
don't oh hell yeah cause it's crazy
cheap i'm just like i gotta do one but
i'm also doing it like in a strategic
way it's not like oh i'm not even gonna
live in it
yeah yeah you're doing it too like
you're playing the game it's like this
is what
is happening right now what's the best
move to make true yeah i'm not really
getting a loan to buy something you
can't afford or whatever yeah
yeah my friend found me a duplex and
he's all like
check this out this duplex rents out for
like uh
if it's fully rented but there's already
tenants there he's like it's 4 600 and
he did the math for me he did all the
work for me
and he's all like basically if you just
you know you know pay the mortgage or
whatever you're already going to be on
top like a thousand bucks a month
oh that's awesome and i'm like what it
like pays itself
basically yeah you just got to get a
mortgage on it did you put an
offer in on on that one no i'm way to
get approved
so you know in the process like first
step is
you got to get approved and then you put
in an offer
and then you go if you get accepted you
go through the escrow and all that stuff
yeah so i'm in the pre-approval phase
it's pretty cool i've been watching the
financial tic talks so they have like
actual people that give yeah they're
really cool
yeah what did they teach you well so the
one i was watching like last night was
how to get a uh was it rolls royce for
free and like one of those big enough
[ __ ] what the [ __ ] yeah so i don't think
that's a financial tick tock
that no no it was so he was basically
like if you want one he was this is how
you do it so he's like
you build up like your revenue stream to
like to the point of like you have some
money
you you what is that what do you need to
so like you basically buy a property
right and the money that you're making
off that property once you rent out all
those units
is paying for that rolex so basically
you're not he's not losing or gaining
but he he obviously has the money to do
that but that's like the smart things
that he's teaching he's talking about
use your assets to pay for your
liabilities
so okay so like spend so it's like for
free spend five years to build up the
passive income to do it yeah well you
shouldn't buy rolex right now if you
don't have anything
or a rolls royce but it's like simple
things like that
i'm like oh i didn't think of that like
that is the smart way though yeah so
it's like just buy a house and
the money you make on a use for the car
don't just go and use the money that you
already have
yeah yeah yeah but that's it's kind of
like
um around business owners and whatever
like this is what we know
but then average people are like people
that
like i don't know like i didn't own any
of this stuff until
i met real estate people or like
business owners or whatever
because we're kind of taught to think
like the only way you make money
is through a job and from that job you
get your paycheck
and that's how you spend it but then
there's all these other rich people out
there that own businesses and they don't
even work in the business or they don't
even
like have to deal with the home like and
they'll buy one in new york and maybe
they
never even been to new york but they
have agents that buy it for them
and then it just collects money and i'm
like how the hell does that happen but
everyday people don't know that though
that's true yeah
spend money to make money what i like
about this whole conversation is that
before we had you know we introduced our
sponsor bart had just disclosed this
confidential information about how he
jacked off to [ __ ] clip art
and now we ended with and he oh yeah i'm
the only one that got
burned no one else described it
i jacked off to everything clip art this
because clip art you need a lot of
imagination it's not very regretful
fap i don't know because they were all
so pleasurable
you've had regret regretful faps
uh i mean you guys know some of the ones
i told you
there's been ones where i'll tell you
all look at the lesbians
inside and then like the girl goes down
and then
the lady has a big hard work one and
then
and then no it's just a normal one and
then she starts sucking it and i'm all
like that it's
hot and then i was just like well i'm
gonna finish because i already started
and then i think that happens a lot yeah
i just i'm like well it's hot i don't
know what to do and then afterwards i'm
like wow
it was the asian one i don't know did
you see the same one there was uh
so there's like these uh asian ones that
i watch and then
there's like these hot girls and then
it's like one of them has a dick but you
don't find out like halfway in the video
and you're like what the [ __ ] but you're
committed
but jimmy she's hot so i was like dude
it's confusing i was watching this
uh travel vlogger he was in the
philippines on pornhub
yeah no no just on youtube and it knows
he's like i i think i said this before
but there's like
three really hot filipino girls right
and he walks by and goes oh beautiful
ladies he goes
we're brothers oh i saw that one yeah
yeah and then in the comments
they're like if they're brothers i'm
questioning my sexuality right now
my most regrettable fap or whatever
was um uh one time i was i was surfing
through a porn site and i came across
one of those animation ones
like i think it was like charizard or
something like a pokemon
but not an anime style animation it was
different
like american cartoon stuff yeah yeah it
was like that and then um
i just i felt really weird afterwards
that i got really turned on by
seeing the inside of the action
so like it's like animation of like them
like pounding from the end what was
charizard [ __ ]
a bulbasaur no i forgot it was two
pokemons though with like a science
video
like it's like like picture of the
camera oh
yeah hentai style seeing the head of the
dick like coming in like
that should turn me on when you're
watching fast and the furious and they
go they turn on the ignition
yeah and then like and then they zoom
out and then you see like the
penetration of it going and then the
ball is like smacking it and i'm like
whoa i feel weird that this is turning
me off wait have you seen this was it
fiery
uh i don't remember because there's
charizard's dude because you saw it
just charged dick's
but it was like an advertisement gif
kind of thing no it was
the actual video she watched
specifically was it on a tuesday because
usually around 12.
i don't know like like simpsons [ __ ]
pop-up and they're [ __ ] that's true
like whenever like
whenever the newest cartoon comes out
when the newest cartoon comes out
there's always like the side
yeah of that latest cartoon in porn form
like when the incredibles came out
oh she's hot incredible mom with mr
incredible and they're having sex and
then like
when frozen comes out frozen elsa is
like having sex and [ __ ] i'm like what
the [ __ ]
yeah i felt the most like wrong
for that one i don't know about your
case me
i think it's similar to joe's experience
except mine was i was looking for a
threesome
and then all guys well there's a girl
but then and then they're like they're
doing the girl but then like in the
middle of the video
the guys start doing the guys i saw
those and i'm like
it's so invested like angry
i don't know about those i didn't sign
up for gay porn i thought it was like a
threesome
a straight threesome porn so what did
the girl do when the guys were on
each other like did she just kind of
like like licking their [ __ ] or
licking their balls
that sounds wonderful big action though
was guy on guy yeah
and i was like that's not what i signed
up for but i'm so invested with the
characters now i'm like i've seen his
face
his face and her face that's why i'm not
trying to switch up the characters right
now
don't watch two guys on a girl because
when i come across a thing that
i'm like i don't like this i just skip
forward
when you're in the moment you're beating
you're just like ah it feels good but i
can't stop
oh no wow what am i watching that's not
what i wanted it's so weird sometimes
the most
the the more shocked you are at like
what you're watching kind of make it
harder yeah the more like turned on you
get you're like this is [ __ ]
weird i'm so disgusted at myself with
just turning me on yeah like the
disgusting part is also kind of like
sensual it's
so funny but then when i see men it
makes me
limp like what [ __ ]
huh but [ __ ] right i've never seen
guys like i don't
yeah i think like that but then well
what are they do what are those twos do
they
end up [ __ ] and that's sword
fighting full-on sex and then the girl's
just kind of like
i'm also here too remember me yeah
but even like when the the camera pans
up to the guy's face when he's about to
come hate that
i don't want to see his [ __ ] why i
was right about the bus and you [ __ ]
ruined it
because my mind is imagining nutting
on what i'm seeing so if it's a man's
face i'm like i'm not trying to [ __ ]
shoot there
oh funny yeah like what happens
when you're about to nut and then the
guy's face pops up do you like hold it
in like holding it
i try cause i'm like i'm not trying to
come there yet and then it goes to the
girl's face and i'm like oh finally
but but it's weird but it it [ __ ] with
my head because it's like
it's like staring into a man's eyes when
you're about to come
oh no right so it's like why does it go
up why do they do that
i hate that [ __ ] because women like it
maybe or other guys like it
oh i know but to me it's not my
my thing you're not just trolling you
probably maybe in the future they'll
make it just for you specific like for
you
i should be a director you should you
should
no it's gonna be the weirdest [ __ ] ever
from the
i always stay away from the two guys
because uh
one time i watched this gangbang and
then same thing dude
they're like doing the girl yeah right
and then
the guy pulls out the other guy's dick
and cleans it up with his mouth and i
was like oh that's not what i signed up
for
why don't the girls like that if the
girl's
cleaning it up no what if they liked it
oh they can like it they can like
you